we haven't thrown the first pitch yet
and bench coach
pat murphy's already been ejected from
the game and this in no doubt
has to do with the strike ball calling
of brian gorman last night and it's
gorman with his back to you in that
scene
and the bench coach pat murphy brought
the lineup out and was ejected arguing
balls and strikes from last night i
think that thing might have almost been
scripted he wanted a piece of brian
gorman there you saw adrian johnson give
him the heave hole i got kicked out of a
game after the game ended one time i've
never seen anybody get kicked out of a
game before the game started that's a
first for me right there take a look at
charlie barnes twin starting pitcher his
stats are brought to you by home
furniture and one two three first inning
for charlie barnes as he sets the
brewers down in order in the first
and the brewers starting pitcher adrian
hauser his stats are brought to you
by home furniture
heavy ground ball pitcher heavy heavy
sinker from adrian hauser he's going to
throw it two-thirds of the time 94 miles
an hour
chopper up the line
polanco hustling and
the ball dropped and falafel should get
credit for an infield hit
the flip seemed to be on target
pitcher trying to find the
ball with his glove in the bag with his
feet donaldson reached safely three
times in yesterday's game
and this one pulled to third they'll
take the lead runner
to retire the side here in the first
inning
there's a drive right center field kane
tracking it looking up and that ball's
off the wall it's the first twins hit
and polanco pulls into second with a
double
see what donaldson could get done to get
the twins on the board
center field
and down for a hit in the decoy by kane
work polanco just did not get a clean
break the ball hit right off the end of
the bat and polanco did not get a good
read on it yeah i think that donaldson
got just enough of that and jorge jorge
knew you see it actually got in on him a
little bit
loaded up for cino green lighted base
hit left center field
polanco scoring donaldson behind him
kepler to third so to second with a
two-run double
now simmons ground ball to third his
first timeout
in search of a two-out hit
and instead he's hit by a pitch
[Applause]
and a third run will score
[Music]
ball four and a walk will produce
another run
and it's four to nothing
and this one in the right field of base
hit kane on his way to third
and the brewers now threatening two on
nobody out in the fifth inning and he
grounded out the third his first time up
in the third inning down a strike to
barnes here
and this one into left field base hit
and the brewers are going to get on the
board as kane trots home
and it's a four to one ball game as
manny pina comes through
here's the 1-1
peterson the left that falls in base hit
here comes another one is telez is home
it's a 4-2 game
and this one ripped into left field the
base hit and runners will hold
station to station here
base is loaded
[Applause]
yelich
right field
pina tagging
here's the throw home they'll cut it off
throw to third and it gets past the
third baseman
that peterson comes in to tie it up
there you go how about that
here's the 3-2
and this time he does indeed strike out
so 1-2 branding for field bar here in
the sixth
it is still 4-4 now teles looks like he
has been thrown out
[Applause]
chase peterson takes over first base in
a 4-4 game rowdy teles tossed
from this one he struck out swinging but
this may have been
the first strike call low that he had a
problem with
then after he struck out he threw his
bat toward the dugout and then said
something to the home plate um fire and
i guess that's all it took
i think he just says something without
throwing the bat he's going to be all
right if he throws the bat and doesn't
say anything he's all right but the
combination of the two
i think that's what got him wrong
to left field and that'll drop safely
and lead off single
and that happened on the inning second
pitch
need a big
hit here to retake the lead after
squandering a four-run lead and there's
the hit
cenote third
and he'll be held there jeffers pokes
one to right and they're loaded up now
with nobody out for simmons rolled to
second
they'll get one
and two but a run scores
coming in as ceno
no run batted in for simmons but the
twins do retake the lead at five four
here's polanco now as a right-handed
batter
and a base hit
molanco's second of the ball game and
he's aboard with one out in the seventh
drill to the left field corner polanco
flying around second that ball stays in
the field of play and polanco coming
around third he will score
with donaldson driving him in with a
double
big spot here
left-handed hitter
right-handed pitcher representing the
tying run here in the ninth
[Applause]
inning and shoots this one into left
field it's going to fall for a base hit
reyes moves up narvae is safe first and
second one down
to simmons to the bag double play
and the twins have won the season series
with milwaukee
another two two-run win six to four they
had a good job by
the twins tonight
got off to an early lead gave it up and
battled back scraped away a couple
scripted crossed a couple runs and the
bullpen another nice job tonight for the
minnesota twins in a 6-4 win